mind your decisions i'm presh tal walker
the square ABCD has a side length equal
to ten suppose E is the midpoint of the
side ad fold the square from the vertex
a along the line segment EB in such a
way that the point a becomes the point F
the question is what is the distance
from the point F two of the line segment
DC I think uncap and um one for the
suggestion pause the video if you'd like
to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
there are many ways to solve this
problem and I will present three
different methods let's get started by
using similar triangles first since E is
the midpoint of the side ad we have that
AE is equal to five
next consider the right triangle AE B we
can calculate its hypotenuse EB using
the gogit theorem EB is equal to the
square root of five squared plus 10
squared which means EB is equal to five
times the square root of five construct
AF let its intersection with the line EB
be the point G since E is equidistant
from the points a and F and B is
equidistant from the points a NF EB is
the perpendicular bisector of a F
consequently these line segments are
perpendicular from here triangle a ge
must be similar to triangle BAE these
are both right triangles that share an
equal angle therefore we can equate the
ratio of the hypotenuse to the longer
side this means EA over a G is equal to
EB over ba we substitute in the values
and then we solve for a G we simplify to
get a G is equal to 10 divided by the
square root of 5 now what's the length
of gf well a G and GF are equal to each
other because EB is the perpendicular
bisector of a F therefore GF is equal to
10 divided by the square root of 5 now
let's construct FH this creates another
right triangle and it shares an angle
with the right triangle a GE therefore a
HF is similar to the right triangle a GE
but from before a ge is similar to the
right triangle BAE
therefore a hf is similar to the
triangle bae this means we have the
following ratios that are equal from
here we substitute in the known values
and we can
simplify and solve for aah we get that a
H is exactly equal to 8
now ad the entire side of the square is
equal to 10 a h plus h D must be equal
to 10 and this means H D is equal to 2
but HD is exactly equal to the distance
from F to the line segment DC therefore
the distance from F to the line segment
DC is equal to 2 and that's our answer
let's now move to the next method of
using coordinate geometry we will first
set up a coordinate system will run the
x-axis through the bottom side of the
square and we'll run the y-axis through
the left side of the square we can then
describe the coordinates of some of
these points the upper corner of the
square will be equal to 10 comma 10
because each side of the square has a
length equal to 10
let's now describe the equation for a
line that passes through these two
points
notice that the line that passes through
these two points will have a slope equal
to 1/2 and we already know that the
y-intercept is equal to 5 therefore we
have the equation 1/2 X plus 5 we then
want to describe the equation of the
line that goes through the point 0 10
and F notice that since these two lines
are perpendicular the slope of this line
will be the negative reciprocal of the
first line so the slope of this line
will be equal to negative 2
and we know it's y-intercept is equal to
10 so this line will have an equation
that's equal to negative 2x plus 10 to
find the intersection of these two lines
we set the equations equal to each other
and we can readily solve that X is equal
to 2 and Y is equal to 6 now this point
will exactly be the midpoint between 0
10 and F suppose F has the coordinates
of P and Q we thus have 10 plus Q all
over 2 is equal to 6 this means Q is
equal to 2 and that's exactly the
vertical distance therefore the distance
from F to the line segment DC is equal
to 2 well now move on to the third
method of trigonometry
to get started recall that the
hypotenuse EB has a length equal to five
times the square root of five
then triangle a EB is congruent to
triangle F EB this means FB has a side
length equal to ten from here suppose
angle a B e is equal to theta that means
angle EB F is also equal to theta now
construct FP that's perpendicular to the
side a B consider this triangle the sine
of two theta will be equal to FP divided
by ten we can then use the sine double
angle formula from here we need to
calculate the sine of theta and the
cosine of theta which we can readily get
from the triangle a B e we calculate the
values for sine of theta and cosine of
theta and substitute those into the
formula we then simplify and we will
solve that FP is equal to eight now
FP is equal to eight but the entire
vertical distance is equal to the side
of the square consequently the distance
from F to the side DC is equal to two
just as before it's a very interesting
problem that you can solve in many
different ways thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]